[Music]
Adele who kicks off her Vegas residency
at the Coliseum tonight 10 months after
she shockingly canceled her shows
so upset and I'm really embarrassed
the singer posted this pic and admitted
she's highly emotional and has never
been more nervous before a show in my
career
of course last night Sin City was the
place to be and our Danny directo was
with all the stars at the Latin Grammys
before hitting the stage in a sequin
black jumpsuit Christina Aguilera
arrived in style fiance Matthew rutler
made a rare public appearance by her
side later in the evening the 41 year
old took home the award for best
traditional pop vocal album the fans the
fighters thank you so much
[Applause]
Anthony who won two trophies made it a
date night with 23 year old fiancee
Nadia perea John Legend was without
pregnant wife Chrissy Teigen and
performer duet with Sebastian yatra
10-time nominee Bad Bunny earned five
Awards including Urban Music album of
the year but the big winner of the night
Rosa
[Applause]
the Flamenco pop singer made history by
becoming the first woman to take home
the honor of album of the Year twice you
get to share this night with your man
does that make a night like that even
more special getting to share with him
of course this makes it even like the
motion bigger everything it feels much
better you guys have crazy chemistry do
you guys Inspire each other and your
music I think definitely definitely
sting doesn't happen you know often
we're really happy
[Music]
foreign